well element you you queue and and quote
iam element 114 has only been made in
very small quantities in fact there's
some argument depending which website
you look on whether they have made one
atom or whether they have made three
atoms of the molecule and all of the
atoms of the element so what does it
matter and I think it's really important
because if you only have one atom of a
compound of an element you can't really
tell very much about it you can't tell
how hard or how strong it is because you
need at least two or more atoms to
interact together to even begin to look
at their properties and really to
understand the material you need a lot
of atoms if you wanted enough to see a
speck of the material you'd be talking
about tens of millions of atoms and even
if you want to use the periodic table to
say well its properties are going to be
like those of the elements above it in
the periodic table then you need quite a
few because for example materials only
become metals if you have quite a large
group of atoms there's some argument
exactly how many whether it's one
hundred or a thousand atoms but you need
a lot of atoms to get metallic behavior
because the electrons from one atom has
to be delocalized throughout the solid
they have to interact together so we
don't really know very much about you
you co diem but if more is made then
we'd be able to understand its chemistry
better